(chant)
L'heure est aux célébrations à
Taïwan, où c'est jour de Fête
nationale. Un événement qui
survient cette année dans
un contexte de vives tensions
avec la Chine.
Pékin affirme vouloir défendre
sa souveraineté sur cette île
qu'elle considère comme faisant
partie de son territoire.
Notre correspondant en Asie,
Philippe Leblanc est à Taipei.
Filez pas une dégagation d'élus
canadiens participent à ces
festivités?
- Ils sont arrésés hier essai
une délégation de cinq
parlementaires et il participe à
une célébration il y a eu un
défiléililitaire et oser parler
à des personnes qui assistent
aux célébrations et on me disait
que c'était important cette
année, encore plus qu'à
l'hatutude d'être ici sur place
pour célébrer la souveraineté,
l'indépendance et la démocratie
de Taiwan.
C'C'est dans ce contexte
que la délégation canadienne
participe aux célébrations,
qui commence et qui vont durer
toute la journée.
- Après les festivités les élus
canadiens vont rencontrer les
politiciens locaux pour parler
de certains enjeux
primordiaux?
- Il y a une rencontre
bilatérale prévue demain avec la
présidence et la délégation
canadienne ira visiter un parc
technologique de construction de
semi-conducteurs, d'micros puces
importants dans tous les
produits électroniques.
Taiwan en construit plus de 95 %
de haut niveau.
On va aller la visiter et tenter
d'en savoir davantage et mettre
l'accent sur la sécurité dans le
détroit de Taiwan et dans la
région.
Ce n'est pas la seule délégation
d'élus qui est en Asie cette
semaine il y a aussi la ministre
des affaires étrangères,
Mélanie Joly qui se trouve en
Corée du Sud. Elle sera aussi au
Japon et ça fait parti de
l'intention d'élaborer la
collaboration du Canada dans le
Pacifique.
On sent l'importance de la
région Asie Sud-Ouest dansaa
région cette semaine